merci Éric alors ce projet culture pour
vous parler très honnêtement c'est un
sujet qui tenait beaucoup à Nicolas
sarcosi pourtant on est tous autour de
lui de sensibilités différentes au sein
de notre famille mais on reconnaît tous
unanimement qu'il voulait réellement que
ce ne soit pas une variable d'ajustement
souvent d'ailleurs c'est le problème des
politiques culturelles je parle sous le
contrôle de Monsieur donieu de Vabre
c'est que quand vous avez gouvernement
qui arrivve dans des conditions
budgétaires qui de toute façon sont de
plus en plus contraintes surtout après
certains héritages c'est souvent la
culture qui trinque et j'espère qu'après
ce travail sur la culture les
gouvernements futurs comprendront
réellement notamment dans notre famille
politique que la culture ne saurait être
une variable d'ajustement mais que c'est
le fondement et l'objectif ultime d'une
société d'un individu la culture est
profondément émancipatrice elle cimente
une société qui est de plus en plus
désagrégé et comme dit Bertran taverni
j'aime beaucoup c'est une arme de
construction massive de la culture et
dans notre société disloquée nous
pensons que c'est quelque chose de
fondamental et que ce serait peut-être
un contesens historique aujourd'hui de
sacrifier la culture au nom d'une
légitime réduction des déficits publics
alors pour parler de cette avec moi de
la première table ronde autour de autour
de moi donc le thème rapprocher la
culture des Français faire de l'école le
sanctuaire de l'accès au savoir et
soutenir la création artistique nous
avons Jean ELTRON qui est directeur
général de la Société des Auteurs
Compositeurs éditeur de musique
laassassem Pascal Rogard directeur
général de la Société des Auteurs et
Compositeurs Dramatiques constance
legrip qui est député européenne
jeunevev Dischamp qui est co-directrice
du théâtre mont-ancier à Versailles
Benoît soless qui secrétaire national
avec moi au spectacle vivant à
l'éducation artistiqueprès à qui je vais
céder la parole après mon intervention
Philippe dallarin qui est directeur
d'excellent conservatoire vice-président
de la Fédération Française de
l'enseignement musical
et et chorégraphique et théâtral
vice-président de l'Union européenne des
écoles de
musique et nous attendons Yve au
petitalo qui est ancien directeur du
Centre d'Art de de grenomme je crois qui
est en qui a eu des petites difficultés
de transport ce matin ce qu'on peut
largement comprendre et
partager donc donc avant de laisser la
parole à Benoît rapprocher la culture
des Français faire de l'école le
sanctuaire de l'accès au savoirs et
soutenir la création artistique c'est
parce que nous pensons que
l'enseignement artistique et la culture
s'enseignent dès le plus jeune âge que
c'est une manière aussi de forger
l'identité d'un individu et et de lui
permettre d'entrer dans l'âge adulte
avec des des bonnes notions la ça permet
aussi de régler parfois de participer au
règlement de de problèmes sociétaux on
parlera peut-être du projet demmos avec
la Philharmonie de Paris dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville qui
marchent extrêmement bien il y a
beaucoup à faire après la réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui a été une
demi-plantade par le gouvernement mais
qui a mis les collectivités
territoriales face à un écueil c'est
comment intégrer la culture à l'école
puisque ça nous était plus ou moins
imposé dans un cadre budgétaire
extrêmement contraint donc il on ne peut
pas parler de la connaissance à l'école
sans parler aujourd'hui de la réforme
des rythmes scolaires et des
conséquences que que cela a eu et puis
la la vision qu'on a peut-être chez chez
nous à droite de l'enseignement
artistique de l'excellence tout ne se
vaut pas je crois qu'il y a pas de de
honte à le dire et quand on voit
notamment ce qui se passe à Paris avec
le tirage au sort dans les
conservatoires il y aurait beaucoup à
dire sur le nivellement par le bas et un
égalitarisme qui va bien au-delà de la
stricte notion d'égalité donc on va
parler de tout ça je laisse la parole à
à
Benoît merci merci beaucoup Florence
pour ce euh cette introduction et c'est
vrai que en t'écoutant on se rend compte
que en parlant d'éducation artistique et
de spectacles vivant mais surtout
peut-être d'éducation artistique on est
bien dans dans le fondement et et et
dans dans la base de ce que doit être
une politique culturelle parce que au
fond former la jeunesse à la culture
c'est capital parce que ça va faire les
spectateurs de demain le public de
demain et ça va faire aussi les futurs
intervenants les professeurs de demain
alors pour rebondir aussi sur ce que a
dit Eric vert c'est vrai que à droite on
a souvent pas été très à l'aise avec la
culture on s'est dit au fond ah ça c'est
le domaine de la gauche alors on on va
pas se fourvoyer on va en faire le moins
possible et en vérité quand on regarde
les politiques culturelles passées et je
parle sous votre contrôle monsieur le
ministre on on voit qu'on a fait
beaucoup de choses à droite aussi pour
la culture et j'ai envie de dire Dieu
merci et moi je me sens d'ailleurs assez
à l'aise en toute humilité pour en
parler parce que je suis comédien et je
me dis ma foi voà je je remercie Nicolas
Sarkozi de m'avoir donné l'opportunité
d'être au côté de Florence sportis
naational à l'éducation artistique et au
spectacle vivant parce que voilà ça
prouve que d'abord on a des choses à
dire qu'on
parler de culture et être de droite et
et qu'on a des idées et on on les a
d'ailleurs développé dans dans ce dans
ce dans ce programme alors pour démarrer
sur l'éducation artistique
véritablement c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
on a un peu un sentiment de gâie parce
que on il y a une forme de de défiance
qui peut se se voir dans dans
l'éducation face à ce qui'est notre
histoire culturelle et notre patrimoine
moi je je suis assez étonné parce que il
me semble que pour appréhender la
culture et même à un moment devenir un
un un un amateur éclairé ou un
professionnel il faut d'abord connaître
ces classiques et aujourd'hui euh dans
l'éducation national il y a presque une
volonté de de tourner le dos à à notre
histoire à nos racines ça devient
suspect où on se fait taxer d'académisme
par parce que on on veut montrer à la
jeunesse notre patrimoine culturel moi
voilà c'est peut-être le premier point
sur lequel on peut on peut lancer la
discussion et d'ailleurs une une des
premières propositions pour être concret
qui a été formulé c'est que dans le
cadre de l'aménagement des rythmes
éducatifs on pourrait vraiment se
demander si plutôt que de faire 3 xis 45
minutes de hip-hop ou de je ne sais quoi
c'est très bien le Hipop d'ailleurs il
me semble peut-être que les élèves
l'étudi enfin l'écoutent déjà le reste
de la journée dans leur baladeur mais
peut-être que ce serait plus utile de
regrouper ces 3 xis 45 minutes pendant
lesquels en vérité on n pas le temps de
faire grand-chose en une véritable
sortie éducative où on emmènerait les
jeunes les les
jeunes au spectacle écouter un concert
en tout cas se confron monter
véritablement à à à une œuvre et moi
c'est vrai que ça me tient à cœur
pourquoi pas à une œuvre classique parce
que c'est aussi comme ça qu'on peut se
se
former
ensuite pour parler de Paris puisqu'on y
est que moi je suis élu à Paris dans le
3e arrondissement c'est vrai que on est
enfin moi je suis atterré par ce qui est
en train de se passer en matière
d'éducation artistiques dans les centres
d'animation et bientôt dans les
conservatoires en quelques mots pour
ceux qui aent pas pas suivi ce que
Madame Hidalgo et Madame polveron sont
en train de faire il a été acté la
suppression des cours individuels de
musique alors on pourrait se dire bon
ils font ça parce que ils se disent
tiens ça va être sympa on va faire
apprendre la musique en groupe mais
d'abord comme l'a très bien dit Florence
ça prouve et on le sait que c'est une
variable d'ajustement budgétaire
évidemment mais ce qui est amusant c'est
de chercher à savoir comment ils vont
motiver l'abandon de ces cours
individuels de musique alors là-dessus
Pauline Veron elle est extraordinaire
parce qu'elle nous dit que c'est pas
l'abandon des cours individuels de
musique non c'est l'expérimentation
d'une pédagogie individuelle par groupe
ah non mais je vous jure je vous jure
c'est vrai c'est exactement dit comme ça
alors là c'est vrai ça fait rigoler et
en même temps je parle sous le contrôle
d'Isabelle tavau du 12e et qui s'occupe
d'éducation musicale
on est atterré atterré parce qu'on se
dit mais mon dieu mais par quel par quel
dogme absurde vont-ils justifier ce qui
en vérité est une mesure d'économie et
je peux vous dire pour être allé voir
les professeurs pour avoir euh
participer à des manifestations pour les
avoir soutenus qui se sentent incompris
et baffoué deème exemple pour vous dire
que euh souvent le le la gauche pour ce
qui est Madame hiidalgo en particulier
n'a pas le monopole de la connaissance
en matière culturelle elle est allée je
crois visiter un conservatoire dans le
12e je crois chez toi ou dans le 13e je
sais plus bon et elle a vu dans les
salles de danse on apprend aux jeunes à
danser qu'il y avait un piano et un
répétiteur pas un répétiteur un
accompagnateur alors elle s'est dit
quand même c'est extraordinaire il y a
un piano et un accompagnateur
dans chaque salle de de danse ça ça va
pas du tout ça va pas du tout ça coûte
beaucoup trop cher il faudrait qu'il un
piano bon éventuellement quelque part et
puis qu'on mette une un CD pour les
cours de danse il y a eu un petit blanc
quand même dans l'assistance les gens on
dit mais madame la mère un cours de
danse on on reprend on arrête on
ralentit la mesure enfin c'est ça ne
peut pas se faire comme ça ah bonelle
dit bon c pas pour le piano et après
pareil sur l'histoire de de la
suppression des des des cours
individuels ils sont dit on va faire ça
par groupe c'est formidable ça fait de
la mixité ils vont parler entre eux ça
va être magnifique et ça fera des
économies mais faire de la musique en
groupe pourquoi pas mais et les
instruments ils ont même pas pensé que
en en en supprimant les en faisant par
exemple des cours de piano par groupe de
3 à 6 bah ils vont pas jouer à tour de
rôle en tournant autour du piano il va
va falloir trois pianos ou six pianos
donc finalement ça ne fonctionnera pas
ils vont finir par jouer un par un par
petit moment segmenté il y aura plus
vraiment cette possibilité ce
rapport du professeur à l'élève pour
essayer bien sûr de de d'apprendre la
musique mais aussi de déceler le talent
chez quelqu'un qui va montrer comme ça
peut-être les prémises de pouvoir être
un musicien professionnel non il y a
toujours cette volonté de lisser comme
ça et et je terminerai parce que vais
être trop long je m'arrêterai pas sur le
le le vraiment le comble du comble c'est
sentant qu'il y avait de la résistance
sur cette réforme il y a une note qui
est sortie euh là pour le coup j'en
parle avec gravité parce que je la
trouve dangereuse incroyable sentant
qu'ils étaient un peu en manque
d'argument pour faire passer cette
réforme ils ont dit et et vraiment he
c'est c'est que c'était dangereux de
laisser un élève seul face à un
professeur parce que qu' y avait eu des
dérives je vais pas prononcer le mot
mais je vous l'avais tous en tête voilà
comment entre autres la ville de Paris
et les socialistes
motivent l'abandon des cours individuels
de musique tout ça pour dire que il y a
beaucoup à faire pour remettre cet enjeu
essentiel au cœur de de notre débat et
de notre
programme merci
benoî alors d'ailleurs par rapport à ce
que tu disais il faut aussi rappeler que
deux premières années du d'Hollande avec
hos ils ont quand même sabré les budgets
culturels comme jamais ce n'est arrivé
depuis raymondb encore Raymond bar ça
avait été sur une année ça était sur 2
ans donc c'est vrai que les ont pas de
leçons à donner néanmoins quand nous
arriverons au responsabilités en 2017 il
faudra pas oublier les vœux
pieux madame dichchan est-ce que vous
voulez déjà
réagir alors moi je vais plutôt parler
de théâtre
puisque je suis un peu la seule
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet avec Benoît
alors deux aspects qui nous paraissent
très importants nous professionnels du
théâtre c'est d'abord que il y a une
rigidité formidable sur ce secteur et
une difficulté à le faire évoluer et
après deux axes prioritaires la
diffusion des œuvres puisqueon crée de
plus en plus et on diffuse de moins en
moins donc ça c'est problème essentiel
et puis la baisse des budgets se porte
prioritairement sur l'artistique et on
commence à entretenir des structures
avec des équipes permanentes extrêmement
importantes qui font vivre des coquilles
vides puisque les saisons se réduisent
d'octobre à mars de novembre à avril et
finalement 6 mois de l'année les les les
théâtres ne fonctionnent pas ou peu
alors diffuser les œuvres c'est vertueux
puisque ceux qui jouent sont payés les
droits d'auteur sont réglés les auteurs
rémunérés et les œuvres sont vu par le
public puisque on a quand même sur tout
le territoire un maillage très important
de de lieux s dramatique scène nationale
scène conventionné théâtre de ville et
que ces lieux il faut qu'il puisse à un
moment accueillir le public le plus
largement possible voilà ça c'est la
première chose sur laquelle je voulais
intervenir ce
matin merci beaucoup
je vais donner la la parole à Noël Tron
pour la
SSM merci m fois je vais peut-être
revenir sur le la première partie de de
votre intervention qui qui porte sur la
question de l'éducation artistique et
culturelle bon vous avez donné quelques
exemples ma présence ici et purement à
politique donc je ne me livrerai aucune
polémique je suis moi aussi assez choqué
qu'on puisse tirer au sort la présence
d'enfants dans des conservatoires quand
serait-il si pour d'autres matières on
avait procédé de même euh je ferai quand
même une petite remarque c'est que au
milieu d'une politique culturelle
française votre votre document des des
républicains le dit bien qui est le
résultat d'une longue et ancienne
tradition avec des personnalités de
toute couleur politique de de de janz à
André merau pour ce qui concerne le
siècle dernier mais mais bien avant il y
a malheureusement dans un rayonnement
français et une politique française de
la culture dans son on s'en orgueil et
et avec raison
un un domaine dans lequel
malheureusement l'exception française
c'est plutôt que nous sommes les plus
mauvais de tous les pays développés
c'est l'éducation artistique et
culturelle alors dans le domaine que je
connais mieux que celui de l'ensignement
de la musique c'est particulièrement
évident or comme nous sommes à peu près
tous fabriqués pareil rien ne
prédétermine euh par exemple le le
public français comme les artistes le le
constatent souvent dans des salles à
chantter FAO euh c'est ce que disait le
le président du du conservatoire et plus
plusieurs artistes qui dirigeaient des
corrales à la Sorbonne avec des
étudiants d'une soixantaine de pays
disait c'est terrible on reconnaît
instantanément les Français c'est ceux
qui chantent
faux pourquoi parce qu'on enseigne plus
on enseigne de moins en moins alors on a
supprimé l'enseignement de la flute pour
ceux d'entre vous qui croi qu'on
pratique encore la la bec à l'école au
passage d'ailleurs on a supprimé
l'enseignement d'une langue vivante dans
ce pays dans une parfaite indifférence
d'accord j'ai une mère latiniste la
question du latin me pose la question
mais moi le fait qu'on ait supprimé
l'enseignement de la musique qui est une
langue dans la plus parfaite
indifférence il y a quelqu n dans ce
pays me pose question parce que c'est de
fait une matière qu'il faut
maîtriser je dirais que enseigner la
culture et les pratiques culturelles à
l'école doit répondre à à trois
objectifs premier le plus évident c'est
de donner le goû de l'art sans rentrer
dans des polémiques sur ce qu'on
qualifie ou pas d'art ou sur
l'enseignement du beau il est certain
que l'un des plus profond reproducteur
des inégalités sociales c'est l'absence
d'un enseignement artistique de qualité
et à l'inverse comme cela existe dans
beaucoup d'écoles grâce à beaucoup
d'enseignants quand on enseigne bien les
arts on permet des découverte nous nous
avons en tant que société d'artistes que
sont les les auteurs compositeurs les
gens qui fabriquent la musique avec des
partenaires qui sont les éditeurs de
musique un peu plus de 157000 membres
aujourd'hui 4000 nouveaux chaque année
quand je discute avec nos jeunes
artistes je suis frappé de voir le
nombre d'entre eux dont la carrière a
été déterminée par une rencontre
artistique notamment à travers
l'enseignement il y a pas de
reproduction sociale inévitable on n'est
pas nécessairement fils d'artiste même
si beaucoup d'artistes sont par ailleurs
des gens qui justement ont vécu dans des
milieux culturels la deuxième chose la
plus la plus déterminante sans doute
aujourd'hui c'est que les pratiques
cultureles les enseignements de la
culture nourrit la capacité à vivre
ensemble et dans un pays je vous renvoie
l'excellent livre de Laurent Bouvet sur
l'insécurité culturelle dont le le plus
gros symptôme de sa crise et
probablement la crise d'identité
culturelle sous toutes ses formes et ça
n'est pas que le cas de la France
l'enseignement de la culture et des
pratiques artistiques à l'école peut
jouer ce rôle déterminant contre toutes
les forme de de fanatisme de de haine et
même contre la perte du sentiment
démocratique et ça on a tendance à
l'oublié c'est absolument fondamental
c'est bien par la culture qu'on apprend
aussi le respect des différences et puis
comme l'avenir appartient à ceux qui ont
la plus longue mémoire à travers
l'enseignement de la culture et d'une
histoire culturelle c'est aussi
l'enseignement de de la construction de
la France que l'on permet aux enfant
puis il y a un troisième point et et je
vais quand même juste le mentionner
c'est qu'il s'agit aussi de parler des
métiers de la création et des mécanismes
qui permettent le financement de la
culture ça n'est pas une matière qu'il
faut réserver à l'université nous par
exemple à laassassin nous avons créé
Sass université qui est une petite
équipe qui s'occupe de travailler depuis
l'école primaire jusque d'ailleurs à
l'université avec les les nouveaux
étudiants en droit pour leur redonner
aux étudiants en drroit le goût
d'étudier le droit d'auteur le goût de
la propriété intellectuelle et pour les
enfants de leur expliquer comment on
fabrique la culture trop de gens y
compris chez nos dirigeants pensent que
au fond voilà un artiste ça VI de
l'airire du temps comme on l'a dit à
l'époque du débat sur la adopie la
musique c'est pas comme les arbres hein
c'est beau mais ça pousse pas tout seul
bon et et Pascal pourrait en parler tout
aussi bien que moi dans ce on a fait un
petit livre pour les enfants de 8 à 11
ans qui raconte par exemple euh la
création des sociétés d'auteur qu'on
doit à beaumarché la SCD la plus la
première des sociétés d'auteur au monde
en matière de droit d'auteur le combat a
précédé le droit sont d'abord des
artistes qui sont mobilisés pour qu'on
reconnaisse leur droit à la création et
le combat que menait bearché à l'époque
ou le le combat qu'on menait les
fondateurs de laassassem qui est une
création de la 2e République donc
beaucoup plus récente 28 février 1851
c'était un combat contre des gens qui
voulai utiliser les œufres sans les
payer bon donc faire un travail de
pédagogie aussi sur les mécanismes de
fonctionnement financement de la culture
c'est important y compris parce que
comme vous le direz dans une table ronde
qui va suivre
euh la culture on a intérêt à donner
envie à nos enfants pour une partie
d'entre eux en tout cas d'y travailler
parce que quel est le point commun entre
les trois grands secteurs en France qui
pèsent plus d'un million d'emplois que
sont le BTP l'hôtellerie restauration et
la culture et l'agriculture allez je
vais en prendre
quatre c'est que la plupart des emplois
dans No secteur ne sont pas
délocalisables voilà et c'est qu'en plus
ils irriguent comme on dit aujourd'hui
j'orreur de ce terme tous les
territoires les territoires bon voilà
dans toute la France pour être plus
concret il y a euh de la culture il y a
des pratiques culturelles il y a des
institutions culturelles l'économie de
la culture c'est euh le 3ème secteur
d'emploi dans ce pays avec 1300000
emplois en Europe c'est 7 million
d'emploi hein rien que le secteur de la
musique en Europe ça pèse plus que
l'industrie des télécommunications bien
évidemment la culture est bien autre
chose que simplement l'économie et c'est
pas mal de rappeler aussi pour ceux qui
ont des doutes existentiels aujourd'hui
sur sur la nécessité de faire un effort
pour défendre le financement de la
culture que ce sont des financements qui
sont vertueux que ce soit les mécanismes
de financement du cinéma avec le modèle
du CNC que ce soit les financements de
tvaut réduite après tout la majorité que
vous représentez à une époque réduit la
TVA sur la restauration je pense qu'elle
a très bien fait il faut pas mettre en
doute la TVA t réduite sur les biens
culturels et et la soutenir ailleurs de
même qu'on subventionne massivement dans
ce pays l'industrie aéronautique et tant
mieux je vois pas pourquoi des gens ont
des problèmes avec l'idée qu'on tien un
certain nombre de mécanisme de finançant
la culture il faut qu'on soit cohérent
bon et puis dernière raison pour tout
cela c'est que non seulement nos
secteurs comme les trois autres que je
vous ai cité sont essentiellement non
délocalisables non seulement comme ces
secteurs dont je viens de vous parler on
y trouve à la fois les plus grands
talents académique des gens qui ont fait
des années de conservatoire mais aussi
des jeunes qui se lèvent tôt qui n'ont
pas de formation et si dans ce pays on
veut régler le problème des 3 400000
jeunes qui sortent s formation chaque
année c'est probablement dans les
secteurs de la culture qu'on va le r
trrouver des emplois y compris je je le
dis devant vous pour défendre le modèle
de l'intermittence intermittence il y a
un certain nombre de dérives qu'il faut
corriger n'empêche que les Scandinaves
ont inventé la flexisécurité
l'intermittence et la flexisécurité il y
a un certain nombre de métiers pour
lesquels on pourra pas faire des gens ni
des fonctionnaires 10 CDI voire même pas
des CDD intermittence ça donne un
minimum de continuité d'accès à la santé
à une forme de protection sociale à la
formation donc c'est ces mécanismes là
aussi je vais terminer par là qu'il faut
expliquer à nos enfants parce que
rayonnement de la France de demain ça va
passer notamment par nos secteurs quels
sont les secteurs de l'économie
française dans laquell vous avez des
numéros 1 mondiaux il y en a plus
beaucoup dans la culture c'est le cas la
première maison de disque au monde c'est
une entreprise française nos grands
studio de cinéma sont des leaders
mondiaux c'est vrai aussi dans les jeux
vidéos c'est vrai dans le théâtre le
festival de Cann c'est le plus grand
rendez-vous mondial du cinéma Arles
c'est les plus grandes rencontres
photographiques du monde la société que
j'ai l'honneur de diriger c'est la plus
grosse société d'auteurs au monde
aujourd'hui on a des numéros un mondial
dans beaucoup de secteurs nous les
acteurs de la culture sommes au cœur de
la révolution numérique hein nous l'an
dernier à la SSM on a traité 589
milliards d'informations unique de
téléchargement ou de streaming pour
pouvoir répartir des droits internet à
nos memb bon il y a pas beaucoup
d'entreprises françaises qui ont ce
genre de volume d'activité ça fait aussi
partie des choses que l'on peut
retrouver dans les enseignements et dans
l'explication de la culture c'est
parfaitement compatible avec les deux
autres grands enjeux que j'ai expliqué
et c'est comme ça que ce pays
pourra construire une position de leader
dans 20 ans quand il y aura 700 millions
de francophones et d'ailleurs il y aura
plutôt 500 ou plutôt 700 millions de
francophone selon qu'on défend ou pas
nos instruments culturels hein vous
recevrez tout à l'heure une table ronde
passionnante je suis sûr que mon ami
Guillaume vous en parlera pour le débat
avec Antoine Baduel de Radio FG au
moment où on parle de l'intérêt des
cotas radio qui sont tous au Chauvin il
faut qu'on ait en tête que si on défend
pas une pratique de la langue française
on a peu de chance que dans 20 ans quand
il y aura 5 à 700 millions de
francophones de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée il y a derrière des
industries culturelles dans lesquelles
les gens pensent dans leur langue
chantent dans leur langue écrivent des
pièces de théâtre dans leur langue
écrivent des romans dans leur langue qui
est notre langue commune je vous
rappelle juste pour conclure sur ce
point de la Francophonie que notre pays
n'est plus le premier pays francophone
du monde et à l'inverse que le français
est la langue qui croit le plus vite
dans le monde donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut se battre sur ces combats je
termine par juste une exemple parce que
je l'ai trouvé dans vos propositions je
le trouve très bien j'avais moi-même en
tant qu'ancien s pro participer à
l'exercice de 100 100 anciens élèves
font 100 proposition j'avais dit si dans
ce pays dans 5 ans on pouvait avoir dans
chaque école une chorale et un orchestre
ça ferait non seulement du bien à la
pratique musicale comme je l'ai dit mais
ça ferait du bien au vivre ensemble
parce que toutes les expériences qui
sont menées vous avez cité des mots et
vous avez bien fait montrre que ceux qui
parlent le mieux des enseignements
artistiques et c'est vrai pour la
pratique théâtrale c'est vrai pour
d'autres pratiques ce sont les autres
enseignants c'est professeur de
mathématique c'est professeur de
français qui qui dit tiens c'est curieux
les enfants d'un seul coup sont plus
disciplinés ils sont plus concentrés il
y a pas que le sport pour donner des
valeurs éthiques dans la vie voire même
c'est plutôt le contraire alors qu'en
matière de pratique artistique voilà
être dans un orchestre c'est apprendre
la discipline c'est apprendre le
travailler ensemble qui fait pas partie
des valeurs premières de l'éducation
nationale dans ce pays qui est plutôt
dans un un hyper
individualisme très très consubstantiel
à la formation de nos élites je vais
vous citer un dernier exemple c'est le
Venezuela hein alors les gens croient
souvent que cet exemple on le Doig à
chavaet c'est pas du tout le cas il y
avait un un philanthrope qui s'appelait
monsieur abreuch qui a une trentaine
d'années a dit pour sortir les les
enfants des favellas de la prostitution
ou la ou du trafic de drogue il y a
peut-être mieux que les paniers de
basket on va leur mettre un violon dans
les mains comme il avit pas le quoi leur
payer un violon prenait des enfants de 3
4 ans et leur faisait faire d'abord les
mouvements ça s'appelle el Systema he el
Systema par la mica ça a produit
certains des meilleurs chefs d'orchestre
du monde quelqu'un comme Gustavo Damel
qui dirige l'orchestre de Los Angeles il
est sorti de ce système c'est 1500
orchestres c'est 500000 enfants qui font
la pratique musicale et c'est un
phénomène mondial le budget total de
système il est d'autour de 500 millions
de dollars alà qu'un pays comme le nôtre
ne puisse pas se poser ce genre de
question qui consiste pas à rajouter
trois bouts de ficelles ici à essayer
d'ouvrir un misérable conservatoire là
mais de se dire dans chaque école il
doit y avoir une troupe de théâtre il
doit y avoir un orchestre il doit y
avoir une corale euh et faire en sorte
que tout enfant qui sort du système
scolaire et travailler au moins une fois
sur un projet avec des vrais artistes
nous on a une opération la SACD on fait
aussi beaucoup dans les écoles n ce qui
s'appelle La Fabrique à chanson une
centaine de compositeurs qui sont allés
dans 100 classes qui travaillent avec
les enfants et les enseignants les les
les coûts sont dérisoires et les
résultats sont formidables donc voilà
pourquoi vous avez raison il faut en
faire à tous égards une priorité
merci alors par rapport à votre
brillante exposé et moi je peux vous
donner exemple de la ville dont je suis
le maire à taverni N on a fait le choix
d'augmenter les budgets culturels mais
de manière très forte et d'instaurer
vraiment des pratiques culturelles à
l'école et donc justement sur ce modèle
vézuélin vézuélien on a créé des classe
orchestre classe orchestre dans un
quartier un petit peu difficile et ce
qui est assez émouvant c'est que des des
gamins qui pour certains étaient pas
très bon à l'école qui sont ça commence
c'est sur des classes de CM1 CM2 en plus
a il peut y avoir une continuité avec
les les chames au collège ont reçu
solennellement leur instrument de
musique al on a fait on a choisi de
faire des cuivres parce que le cuivre s
prend assez facilement les instruments
de cuivre et certains gosses nous ont
dit c'est le plus beau jour de ma vie et
c'est des et ça marche et ça marche il y
a aucun problème ils apprennent
l'altérité à travailler ensemble la
rigueur parce que le on croit souvent il
y a une manière un peu méprisante
parfois de parler des artistes en disant
ouais bon c'est un truc de Bobo ils se
font plaisir c'est c'est un loisir pas
du tout la culture c'est exigeant et
justement ça leur apprend à travailler
et que derrière il y a un effort à faire
et je trouve que la quand on a une
pratique musicale on apprend l'humilité
on apprend que tout est perfectible
qu'on est on sera jamais un excellent
musicien en tout les cass la perfection
n'existe pas je sais de quoi je parle et
et pour ces enfants là c'est c'est
vraiment à plus par rapport à ce que
vous disiez aussi sur l'enseignement
artistique à l'école ce qu'il faudrait
c'est former les professeurs dans les
pays anglo-saxon en Allemagne ou dans
les pays scandinaves les enseignants
sont formés au champ et donc ils sont
formés pour
apprendre aux enfants avoir une oreille
musicale à savoir ce que c'est que la
polyphonie quand ils ont 6 7 ans ils ont
déjà une très bonne oreille ils savent
très bien chanter mais parce que les
professeurs sont formés à ça donc il y a
aussi le le la formation des des
professeurs à revoir alors justement
Philippe darin donc directeur de
conservatoire vice-président des euh la
Fédération des euh françaises
d'enseignement musical et l'Union
européenne des écoles de musique vous
pouvez nous nous parler de de la
pratique musicale à l'école et peut-être
aussi de la nécessité de renforcer le
rôle des dumistes
ou il y a des choses très importantes
qui viennent d'être dites euh je
voudrais revenir d'un mot quand même sur
la question budgétaire et sur la baisse
historique du budget du ministère de la
Culture qui s'est traduit en 2015 par
une suppression des des subventions des
financements de l'État au conservatoire
classé conservatoire rayonnement
régional et départemental c'est du
jamais vu heureusement grâce à la
mobilisation de parlementair d'élus de
terrain et d'association comme celle que
je représente le ministère a fait volte
face en 2016 a rétabli les crédits et
dit mais c'est une année électorale
qu'en 2017 il va les augmenter en
réalité je crois que depuis que que
malerot avait parfaitement fixé les
choses il y a un équilibre à trouver
entre la démocratisation et l'excellence
et dans notre pays on est souvent
prisonnier des idéologies c'est ce qui
se passe en ce moment c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est ce que vous décriviez dans
les conservatoires parisiens il y a pas
seulement un souci budgétaire il y a
vraiment de l'idéologie de dire ce
système n'est pas bon il faut le
remplacer par autre chose or cette autre
chose existe il ça vient d'être décrit
c'est les classes orchestes et le
système vézuélien et il faut savoir
qu'en Europe ces systèmes se répandent
en il y a un système qui s'appelle un
instrument pour chaque enfant dans le
cadre de l'école qui marche extrêmement
bien en Angleterre il y a les mêmes
dispositifs dans les pays scandinaves et
que ça ça ne doit pas remplacer l'action
des conservatoires mais que ça doit être
totalement complémentaire de l'action
des
conservatoire parce que il faut pas
commettre le contresens de penser qu'un
conservatoire c'est un lieu conservateur
en fait c'est un lieu où on transmet un
patrimoine et c'est extrêmement
important
par rapport à notre identité il faut
continuer à le faire on doit préserver
ce patrimoine on doit le transmettre aux
jeunes générations mais en même temps ce
sont des lieux aussi d'innovation
d'innovation pédagogique des lieux
ouverts à la création artistique et donc
c'est un équilibre à trouver entre ces
nouvelles formes d'apprentissage et puis
ce qui fait quand même l'excellence de
notre pays on a d'excellents enseignants
vous disiez effectivement l'éducation
artistique est un peu la risée de de des
autres pays mais en fait notre système
est assez envié nous avons le plus grand
réseau d'écoes de musique et d'art
d'europein
460 établissements classés mais
également 1500 écoles municipales et au
moins 3000 écoles associatives donc
c'est c'est un réseau extrêmement dense
et en même temps parce qu'il est
extrêmement divers il est fragile il y a
des questions d'harmonisation
d'homogénisation de répartition sur le
TER territoire qu'il faudra essayer
vraiment de traiter dans dans les années
qui viennent l'objectif c'est que chaque
enfant de ce pays voir chaque adulte est
un accès à la pratique à la pratique
artistique parce que ça a été dit c'est
une évidence de le dire mais c'est tout
simplement au cœur de la civilisation et
ça n'est pas un hasard si la barbarie
s'en prend d'abord à la culture d'abord
à la musique il y a un excellent film
que vous avez peut-être vu qui s'appelle
am booktu Qui qui retrace ça de manière
absolument magnifique voilà donc il y a
un combat aussi à mener en faveur de
l'excellence et et des valeurs auxquels
nous croyons le dernier point que je
veux dire c'est qu'il faut éviter aussi
une confusion dans nos débats c'est pas
du tout le cas aujourd'hui mais ça été
le cas notamment dans l'action des deux
premièr ministres de la Culture de ce
quinquena c'est une confusion entre
l'éducation artistique est une
sensibilisation très large qui doit
toucher tout le monde et l'enseignement
artistique spécial
et fleur pèlerin et Aurélie philippti
pour ne pas les nommer ont essayé
d'attirer en fait de dissoudre en
quelque sorte l'inignement artistique
spécialisé dans l'éducation artistique
c'est pour ça que les budgets ont été
coupés et on a besoin des deux là à
nouveau c'est une question d'équilibre à
trouver voilà on doit marcher sur ces
deux piliers la démocratisation et
l'excellence et je crois que dans les
années qui viennent il faudra et pour le
prochain quinquena il faudra vraiment
traiter ces questions parce que elles
sont au cœur du vivre ensemble au cœur
de la possibilité pour tous de de
d'avoir un rapport à l'autre qui soit
harmonieux et non pas
conflictuel merci Philippe alors sous
l'angle des des financements je vais
laisser la parole à Constance legrip qui
a une expérience comme conseiller
élyiséenne déjà on peut le dire et comme
députés
européens merci Florence bonjour à à
chacune et chacun d'entre vous je
voulais notamment rebondir par rapport à
ce qui a été dit précédemment et aux
thématiques esquissé par Jean-Noël Tron
parlant de pédagogie et parlant de
droits d'auteur l'éducation artistique
ça me fait penser bien sûr à la
pédagogie et je pense qu'il est très
important que nous notamment les
républiain la formation politique que
nous sommes réaffirmions un certain
nombre de valeurs et un certain nombre
de principes et parmi ces valeurs et ces
principes auxquels il nous faut très
ardemment très résolument affirmer notre
attachement il y a celui du droit
d'auteur celui du droit d'auteur qui est
à l'heure actuelle en Europe dans le
monde soumis à de fortes pressions
soumis à de fortes menaces et dont
certains
au travers
d'idéologie libertaire libertarienne et
sous prétexte de l'accès de tous à la
culture et de la
gratuité des contenus culturels de
gratuité de la culture veulent abollir
les effets les effets bénéfiques qui dit
droit d'auteur dit reconnaissance du
travail reconnaissance du mérite
reconnaissance de la création le droit
d'auteur c'est la pierre angulaire c'est
d'abord une invention française jean-ë
l' cité bearché les premières sociétés
d'auteur c'est la reconnaissance du
travail c'est un droit et de la création
c'est un droit moral et c'est un droit
patrimonial c'est la pierre angulaire de
toute activité artistique de toute
activité créatrice de toute activité
culturelle et donc c'est à cet égard
fondamental on n pas trouvé mieux que le
droit d'auteur à travers les siècles
pour reconnaître le travail la création
le mérite et donner la juste
rémunération aux aux artistes aux
auteurs aux créateurs de leur travail
leur permettre de jouir du fruit de leur
travail et si possible de vivre du fruit
de leur travail ce principe il est même
s'il a maintenant quelques siècles qu'il
s'est répandu à travers le monde il est
éminemment moderne et à l'heure où nous
traversons une révolution industrielle
numérique la révolution digitale qu'
bouleverse tout qui bouleverse tous les
paradigmes économiques sociétaux dont on
voit bien que aucun secteur aucune
activité humaine ne sortira indemne il
est important de réaffirmer que le droit
d'auteur que certains notamment en
Europe notamment dans les institutions
européenne notamment au sein du
Parlement européen cherche à présenter
comme un droit en quelque sorte ancien
desuets ringard appartenant au siècles
passés et plus du tout adapté à cette
société moderne ouverte où tout circule
où tout le monde peut avoir accès à tous
les contenus culturel à toutes les
informations à toutes les connaissances
à toutes les musiques et ce ce droit
d'auteur il est éminemment moderne c'est
même l'un des plus modernes des droits
de la propriété intellectuelle parce
qu'il est immatériel il est immatériel
qu'est-ce qui est plus adapté en réalité
à cette révolution numérique à cette
révolution virtuelle que un droit de
propriété qui est un droit immatériel
qui n'est pas strictement attaché à un
objet physique à une propriété physique
au sens classique une maison un objet
une voiture et cetera et cetera donc je
crois qu'il est important c'est un
combat pour une certaine idée de la
création une certaine idée de la culture
mais également pour un CRE de valeurs
qui nous sont chères à nous les
républicains la reconnaissance du
travail la reconnaissance du mérite la
reconnaissance de la propriété le droit
d'auteur c'est la reconnaissance de
toutes ces valeursl
amiler le droit d'auteur affaiblir le
droit d'auteur sous prétexte de le
moderniser sous prétexte de le faire
passer du 20e au 21e siècle et donc de
considérer que il serait un obstacle une
entrave à la libre circulation des
œuvres et au fait que que tout un chacun
puisse accéder tout à fait librement
comme il souhaite jouir sans entrave et
donc accéder au contenu culturel à tous
les produits culturels sans sans entrave
et bien ce
serait tuer un certain nombre de
mécanismes de financement de la création
culturelle de la création artistique
parce qu'on a pas trouvé de plus
efficace de plus efficace et de plus
performant que le droit d'auteur pour
soutenir et financer la production
culturelle la production artistique et
je pense que pour nous force politique
c'est important de réaffirmer notre
attachement à ce principe de dire
également et là je rebondis sur la
pédagogie au aux jeunes génération qui
quelquefois un peu nos jeunes
compatriotes nos enfants nos
petits-enfants nos frères nos sœurs et
quelque fois peut-être à l'insu de leur
pleing gré se sont trouver en situation
de violer le droit d'auteur de baffouer
le droit d'auteur quand on fait du
déchargement illégal quand on pense
qu'on peut partager à l'infini des
œuvres sur Internet on se trouve en
train de bafouer ce droit euh au euh de
reconnaissance du travail du créateur ce
droit de la propriété qui est un droit
moral qui est un droit immatériel qu'à
un auteur un créateur un artiste à
pouvoir être récompensé rémunéré reconnu
dans son travail il y a des batailles
assez sérieuses qui se font jour
actuellement dans les institutions
européennes au sein du Parlement
européen notamment parce que
effectivement sous prétexte de faire
entrer l'Union européenne nos pays
européens de plein pied dans l'ère
digitale un certain nombre de de de
forces règlementaires la Commission
européenne d'autres mouvements d'autres
organismes essayent de voir comment euh
aplanir n'est-ce pas euh les obstacles
faire disparaître les frontières permet
le libre accès si poss possible
gratuitement de toutes et de tous au
contenu culturel et donc veulent
s'attaquer au droit d'auteur sous
prétexte qu' ne serait pas moderne
encore une fois et que ce serait quelque
chose de parfaitement inadapté à la
révolution numérique et donc il est
important d'être être mobilisé important
d'envoyer des messages politiques en
terme de valeur en terme de principes ce
que je viens de d'exposer très très
imparfaitement devant vous mais
également en terme d'efficacité et de
pragmatisme nous avons besoin nos pays
européens la France bien évidemment mais
il y a d'autres grandes puissances
culturelles grands pays qui ont des
traditions des histoires culturelles
importantes en Europe puissent euh
réaffirmer leur attachement à la
production artistique à la création à la
production culturelle réaffirmer leur
attachement à une certaine idée de notre
identité européenne le projet européen
notre identité européenne sont
grandement culturels notre continent se
caractérise par une très forte richesse
culturelle patrimoniale musicale
artistique au sens large toutes les
disciplines artistiques nous nous
caractérisons par une très forte
richesse mais également par une très
forte diversité artistique et culturelle
dont bien évidemment on voit bien
diversité linguistique mais toute type
de diversité qui caractérise notre
continent donc je rappelle que voilà
pour l'Union européenne en tout cas la
la devise le le slogan c'est uni dans la
diversité et donc le combat pour le
droit d'auteur il participe de cette
défense du patrimoine et de l'identité
culturel qui sont au cœur du projet
européen donc il y a de grandes
batailles les experts qui sont présents
à cette table ronde le savent au sein
des institutions européennes pour porter
un sonbre de valeurs porter un certain
nombre de thématiques et s'assurer que
les éventuels projets de révis de tel
tel règlement européen de tel ou telle
directive européenne ne viennent en rien
diminuer affadir affaiblir aniler le
droit d'auteur encore une fois
pierreangulaire de toute création notre
convention consacrée à la culture doit
reconnaître le mérite le travail
l'effort la création des artistes la
création culturelle au sens
noble
merci qu'elle regarde nous donner sa sa
vision sur les politiques culturelles
merci alors il est difficile de le
parler aussi bien du droit d'auteur que
Constance parce que là elle m'a elle m'a
pris tout mon discours de défense du
droit d'auteur et et c'est vrai que le
droit d'auteur il est né en 1777 avec
beau marché et que c'est une création
française nous devons la défendre c'est
une idée qui parcourt le monde et que
nous devons défendre alors Eric a dit
quelque chose de juste c'est que la
droite est assez mal à l'aise avec la
culture en général et elle a tort de
l'être parce que si on rappelle les
grands succès le grand succès de la
bataille du Gat qui est la mère de
toutes les batailles c'est la bataille
de l'exception culturelle qui est donc
le droit de décider une politique
culturelle sans être soumis aux règles
du commerce international elle était
gagnée par Édouard Baladur qui était à
l'époque Premier ministre euh le
quinquena de Nicolas Sarkozi a été
marqué par un maintien des budgets
culturels alors que les débuts du
quinquenin de François Hollande ont été
quand même marqués c'était une grande
déception parce que Jean-Marc herraud
avait une réputation de mère culturelle
par une chute du budget de la culture
depuis la chute a été enrayée il faut
être objectif mais sur le spectacle
vivant il y a un problème qui a été créé
par la politique depuis quelques années
c'est que le spectacle vivant est
financé aux 2 tiers par les
collectivités territoriales hein les
villes les départements les régions et
que les restrictions qui ont été portées
de politique publique vers les
collectivité territoriale retentissent
sur le financement de la culture donc il
y a beaucoup de troubles de théâtre de
centes dramatique qui actuellement sont
en difficulté il y a des articles dans
la presse à cause de ces restrictions
sur le droit d'auteur Nicolas sarosi je
le dis au rebours de ses interélectoraux
parce que il y a plus de Pier
que d'auteur artiste c'est très
compliqué de défendre le droit d'auteur
au Parlement Renaud donne Dieu le vavre
en sait quelque chose bon Nicolas
Sarkozi a défendu et a toujours défendu
le le droit d'auteur il a créé une
institution qui s'appelle la doopie qui
était très dénigré pour assurer la
protection du droit d'auteur laadopie
dans sa partie détection de la piraterie
avertissement fonctionne très bien si on
relisait les débats on nous décrivait le
meilleur démon de quelque chose
d'intrusive dans la vie des particuliers
ça fonctionne très bien le seul problème
c'est que ça n'est pas efficace parce
que derrière il y a pas de sanction et
que il faudrait revenir à des sanctions
plus normales on a peut-être été trop
loin avec la suspension de l'abonnement
internet qui sont des systèmes d'amende
qui permettrai d'ailleurs de de faire
fonctionner le système donc la bataille
du droit d'auteur est une bataille qui
est engagé qui est une bataille qui doit
être menée parce que tous les services
Inter internet
essayent de gagner de l'argent sans
rémunérer les droits d'auteur les
grandes entreprises les pires ennemis
actuels du droit d'auteur ce sont les
grandes entreprises internet en général
américaines qui ont la caractéristique
un de ne pas payer d'impôt il y a quand
même une faiblesse générale de
l'ensemble des États européens et
l'Union européenne là-dessus bon on a vu
récemment il y a eu un débarquement de
beaucoup de contrôleurs du fisque
chez Google mais il y a beaucoup
d'autres entreprises qui font pareil et
qui ont la caractéristique de ne pas
payer les contributions culturel
actuellement Netflix fait du chiffre
d'affaires sur le territoire français et
de la concurrence déloyale aux
opérateurs français qui eux payent une
contribution au Centre national du
cinéma alors j'ai lu bien que l'ayant
reçu tardivement le programme des
républicains je dois dire que j'ai vu
avec plaisir que vous repreniez quelque
chose qu'on a commencé de façon modeste
à mettre en œuvre à la SACD avec les
autres sociétés d'auteur qui est le
programme à l'artiste à l'école qui
consiste envoyer un artiste dans l'école
de son enfance et euh pour parler de
culture de création défendre le droit
d'auteur et cette opération que nous
menons de façon modeste parce qu'il y a
à peu près actuellement qu'une
cinquantaine d'écoles touchées qu'on
pourrait étendre rencontre un très grand
succès parce que un l'artiste est ému et
envie d'aller sur les dans l'école de
son enfance alors je dis c'est plus
facile de trouver des lycées à Paris que
des lycées agricoles en province bon
pour avoir les artistes mais on on
essaie de de diversifier et d'autre part
les écoliers surtout quand il y a des
enseignants qui s'intéressent au sujet
sont absolument ravi d'avoir une
personnalité qui leur décrit à la fois
l'intérêt d'une carrière culturelle mais
aussi les risques d'une carrière
culturelle parce que les carrières
culturelles sont des métiers quand même
extrêmement difficiles et et souvent
aléatoire j'ai vu aussi une proposition
qui est très intéressante qui a pas pu
être mise en œuvre sous le quinquena de
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est la création d'un
Centre national de la musique parce que
c'est vrai que le cinéma l'audiovisuel
on un outil de financement
extraordinairement puissant qui est le
Centre national du cinéma qui bénéficie
de taxes affectées il y a 650 millions
d'euros par an qui irrigue la création
cinématographique et audiovisuelle et le
spectacle vivant n'a pas le même outil à
part le petit centre national des
variétés donc je pense qu'il faut aller
dans cette voie mais je pense qu'il faut
élargir et aussi s'intéresser au
spectacle vivant parce que comme l'a dit
jeunevèv le spectacle vivant a un énorme
problème on crée beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de pièces qui sont créées mais
la moyenne des diffusions des pièces du
théâtre public c'est à peu près 17 18 on
joue très peu et encore moins pour les
balais où c'est 6 7 donc il y a un gâchi
formidable de voir toute cette création
qui ne circule pas qui n'est pas
diffusée et qu'on devrait encouragé par
des outils de soutien à à la diffusion
donc je ne parlerai pas du programme
audiovisuel parce que c'est le sujet de
l' taable ronde et que j'ai quelques
désaccords avec le programme qui m'a été
soumis mais ça on en parlera entre nous
mais voilà je suis non je reviens sur ce
qu'a dit constance c'est que euh
vraiment je moi je dois beaucoup au
président sarcosi pour avoir défendu le
droit d'auteur dans une période où ça
n'était pas facile de le faire ou
d'ailleurs c de ses amis ne
l'encourageit pas à le faire il a connu
des problèmes au Parlement aussi avec sa
majorité et il a été sur ce plan là d'un
courage et d'une détermination
absolue merci je vais laisser la parole
à Yve au petit ad s'il vous plaît
oui merci bon beaucoup de choses ont été
dites donc je je vais essayer si vous
voulez de de trouver je dirais des
points particuliers qui me tiennent à
cœur et qui sont complémentaires de ce
que vous avez pu dire je en terme
d'enjeux d'enjeu au niveau d'une
politique de l'État et d'une politique
nationale en matière de culture il y a
un premier point qui me semble
extrêmement important et je prendrai
quelques exemples puisque ça nous permet
de recouper notamment les questions
d'éducation artistique c'est la
différenciation à l'intérieur des
politiques publiques je vais prendre
quelques exemples je crois que je vous
allez comprendre très très vite de de
quoi je veux parler en quand nous avons
fait
dans ce pays le bicentenaire de la
Révolution Barbara Hendrix est venu
chanter quand il s'est agit n'est-ce pas
de rendre hommage au poilu de Verdin
c'est blackem qui a été invité alors
pourquoi j'ai choisi ces exemples là je
en dehors de tout esprit polémique c'est
bien pour indiquer effectivement ce
qu'on appelle les sociologues de l'art à
l'chîn internationale et notamment
anglo-saxon appelle la crise des
cultures savantes c'estàd
qu'effectivement l'un des enjeux les
plus important pour nous aujourd'hui en
matière de politique publique
d'éducation artistique c'est bien de
différencier ce qui seraiit des
pratiques à un certain moment
communautaire qui deviennent des
pratiques marqueté au niveau de
l'industrie du disque notamment et bien
savoir faire la différence il s'agit pas
de hiérarchiser mais bien de faire la
différence et pour Verdin moi je pensais
à quelque chose de de tout à fait
particulier là je reviens encore sur un
exemple qui est celui de la musique
c'est qu'il y a effectivement une
histoire de la musique qui est liée à la
Première Guerre mondiale et tout
particulièrement à Verdin et qu'il est
tout à fait dommage par contre leurit
pas rendu hommage je pense à au quator
accorde donc que le général min avait
recréé autour de lui composé d'un
composite donc d'un compositeur qui
s'appelle Capel et de deux virtuoses
donc de cette génération qui sont du
rosoir et marchand les deux y on été
pris du Conservatoire donc qui ont
effectivement composé donc un certain
nombre de choses notamment la marche
héroïque de la 5e division et je pense
que c'était plutôt l'occasion au moment
de Verdin de rappeler cette histoire de
la musique française liée donc à la
guerre et voir puisqu'il s'agissait
également de réconcilier donc de fêter
cette réconciliation de donner donc donc
de demander à un quateur Allemand de
jouer l'équateur debsy sachant que
paulindemis donc célèbre compositeur et
interprète allemand donc les a joué en
1917 en Allemagne et à pendant le décès
de debusy s'est arrêté et a rendu
hommage à debusy en Allemagne pendant la
guerre sachant que de Bui de son côté
détestait l'Allemagne et le disait à qui
voulait l'entendre donc je crois voilà
un exemple si VZ que je donne quelques
exemples de ce qui me semble être un
enjeu extrêmement important en matière
d'éducation artistique c'est la
différenciation et non pas la
hiérarchisation sachant que si on ne le
fait pas on aboutit à des sortes d'ERM
culturels où effectivement les choses on
F une sorte de bouillie de chat
intellectuel où les choses sont mélangé
sans devoir les discriminer je crois
qu'il est important de les rappeler
d'autant que j'allais dire que toute
bonne action a son revers et comme vous
le savez l'enfer est pasé de de bonnes
attentions c'est qu'à vouloir favoriser
des pratiques donc communautaires ou
identitaires qui ne seraient pas je veux
dire attacher une une identité nationale
le le pendant c'est qu'on crée des
ghetos en réalité qu'on ne fait que
renforcer des gettteau qui sont
existants donc ça je crois que c'est
important en tout cas c'est un point de
vue je je sais que nous sommes un
certain nombre à partager qu'il faut
dire d'autant que ce qu'on appelle les
cultures savantes passe aussi par un
apprentissage ce qui n'est pas le cas de
toutes les formes d'expression
culturelles ça c'était le premier point
sur lequel je voulais insister le
deuxième là il est propre au secteur
d'activité que je représente
c'est-à-dire les arts plastiques je
crois et ça n'est pas un secret de dire
que ce modèle que nous avons construit
dans laaprès- guuerre est en parfaite
crise aujourd'hui et que il s'agit
réellement de le rep de le renouveler et
notamment pour les artistes de de
d'apporter et les structures donc qui
ont pour objet de de soutenir l'action
des artistes de créer des outils adaptés
donc à des pratiques contemporaines des
outils qui soient effectivement des
outils juridiques qui permettent d'aller
vers des formes nouvelles donc de
structure des outils financiers qui
permettent par exemple d'aller vers des
fonds de dotation adaptés donc un
certain nombre d'établissement et puis
je dirais assez simplement pour les
personnels de d'établissement qui ont en
charge Ré ement la création la plus
contemporaine non pas d'aller vers une
forme d'intermittence donc de de de de
l'art contemporain des arts plastiques
mais j'allais dire de réfléchir à des
formes de contrat granulair ou de ce
qu'on appelle l'économie postsariale
c'est d'éviter l'enquistement donc
d'équipe qui serait en charge de la
création la plus contemporaine dont on
sait que elle est sans cesse changeante
donc sans cesse déstabilisante et qu'il
est très important de réfléchir donc à
des outils qui seraient qui seraient
adapté le troisème point sur lequel
alors qui va recouper un peu je crois la
la trisème table ronde c'est la question
donc de l'Internationale qui est une
question clé donc au cœur même de l'art
contemporain plus peut-être que les
disciplines qui ont la langue donc au au
cœur de la activité question
internationale dont on a vu puisque
beaucoup de mes collègues ont d'ailleurs
j'allais dire avec beaucoup de beaucoup
de courtoisies donc se sont regroupés
pour protester courtoisement contre la
nomination donc la procédure de
désignation de l'artiste français pour
la Bienale de Venise et là je crois
qu'on est fasse un airement
bureaucratique absolu c'est-à-dire je
crois qu'il faut redonner dans ce
secteur-là aux artistes je veux dire des
outils qui leur permettent effectivement
euh de travailler à l'échelle
internationale sur des critères qui sont
réellement des critères internationaux
voilà puis tout dernier point avant de
de vous passer la parole puisque je et
je vous invite à à à le à le faire à
visiter cette exposition saidouet donc
que j'ai organisé au Grand Palais euh
c'est la question dans notre
enseignement et notre culture de euh je
dire de notre héritage euh héritage qui
passe effectivement par cette période
colonial qui est un peu absent donc de
de nos pratiques culturelles et qui est
un ferment identitaire l'exposition
saidoueta donc dont je je parlais et la
démonstration s'il le fallait à un
moment donné de la rencontre entre des
cultures natives et la culture qui était
celle certes des colonie mais qui a
permis l'émergence d'une culture
spécifique dans des pays aujourd'hui où
malheureusement nous sommes très
absents puisque comme vous le savez les
les au niveau donc de la la politique
donc du minist des Affaires étrangères
on est en train de fermer un petit peu
partout donc des établissements donc de
de de présence de la culture française
et je crois que là c'est un enjeu majeur
il faut que nous soyons vraiment présent
dans ces zones d'influence stratégique
et historique qui sont les nôtres je
pense notamment à l'Afrique avant
évidemment que je veux dire nos amis
africain ne s'intéresse plus qu'à la
culture chinoise voilà merci
merci
alors avant de de donner la parole à la
salle pour que vous puissiez nous poser
quelques questions avant que nous
passions à la seconde table ronde et
rester dans les temps nous sont imp
partis sous l'œil vigilant d'éc
vert on voulait quand même dire avec
Benoît et au nom de de David et puis de
du du président
Sarkozi contrairement à ce que l'on peut
croire nous sommes profondément attaché
à l'intermittence on considère que aller
contre l'intermittence ce serait tuer la
culture dans ce pays alors il y a
évidemment des abus il y en a aussi
beaucoup du côté des entreprises il y a
notamment une entreprise publique
audiovisuelle qui euh je pompe largement
le système des intermittents on
abuse pour des raisons évidemment
budgétaires ce qui est assez scandaleux
donc ce serait bien d'avoir un regard un
peu moins caricatural peut-être un peu
moins stigmatisant ce qui n'empêchera
pas évidemment de de travailler plus
tard à des à un système qui soit un peu
plus équitable et qui limite les abus
mais euh tout en ayant conscience de
cela on voulait rattacher rappeler notre
attachement
àinmittence oui c'est vrai et pour dire
en de mots que sur sur ce dossier au
combien épineux on a un peu travaillé
dans tous les sens parce qu'au fond on a
cherché à à savoir s'il fallait
rallonger la période d'indemnisation la
raccourcir s'il fallait que le nombre
d'heures soit plus grand moins grand
qu'il ait des carences pas de carences
au fond nous c'est vrai qu'on est
attaché à ce système on le dit et on le
proclame haut et fort mais on pense
qu'il y a quand même des des
véritables voies qui ont pas été
totalement explorées véritablement
chercher à combattre la fraude ça n'a
pas vraiment été fait moi je travaille
dans le spectacleant je su comien et je
peux vous dire qu'on on connaît tous les
petits systèmes qui permettent de
frauder et il y a il y a pas vraiment de
mécanisme qui a été fait pour lutter
contre ça et aussi je pense que
peut-être une des voies vers lesquelles
on devrait travailler ce serait de se
dire au fond que peut-être trop de
personnes sont entrées dans ce système
bénéficie aujourd'hui de ce syème et
c'est ce qui l'affaiblit alors peut-être
qu'il faudra à l'avenir avoir le courage
de de de se dire que par l'obtention
d'une carte professionnelle pourquoi pas
par exemple il va falloir mieux définir
qui a droit à ce statut spécifique et
qui n'y a pas droit ça c'est un courage
politique parfois pour sauvegarder un un
statut spécifique que de de dire voilà
qui peut en bénéficier ou pas merci
alors est-ce qu'il y a des questions
dans la salle il y a forcément des
questions
madame Marie Rochette del land je suis
adjointe à la culture à la mairie de
Belfort le député maire et Damien
messelot je suis membre de du bureau de
la FNCC j'ai participé à la commission
culture grâce à David Hervet et Boutin
j'ai je voudrais citer deux petits enfin
courts exemples à Belfort de réalisation
à Belfort qui ouvre sur une question à
propos du soutien de la à la création
artistique nous redynamisons à Belfort
la fête de la musique pour la 2uxe année
et nous nous sommes le dou détonnateur
de cette fête de la musique en on a un
canal le Conseil des quartiers entre
autres comme canal de communication et
nous mettons en lien les structures
accueillantes qui peuvent être une
quarantaine de enfin qui sont une
quarantaine de commerces plus les
structures culturel classique et les
musiciens un deuxième exemple nous
sommes nous avons beaucoup de d'acteurs
culturels qui travaillent beaucoup
ensemble le Centre chorégraphique
national travaille bon ça c'est assez
classique avec la scène nationale
travaille aussi avec le théâtre de
marionnette avec une compagnie de
théâtre amateur voilà il y a beaucoup de
d'interaction la question avec les les
musées aussi la question est comment
pousser d'autres acteurs culturels à
faire de même parce qu'en effet dans
certaines villes les acteurs culturels
sont plus
concurrents que que travaillons ensemble
alors je sais pas qui veut prendre la
parole mais déjà je pense que le premier
rôle c'est celui du maire et là on va
peut-être c'est pas l'jet de la table
ronde mais il y a tout une question sur
les strates territoriales qui est pilote
des politiques culturelles et avec les
dernière
loi réforme territoriale c'est une vraie
question qui s'est posée notamment au
niveau du rôle de la région est-ce que
la région doit être pilote des
politiques culturelles quels sont le
rôle des intercommunalités des des
communautés d'agglomération à mon avis
il faut qu'ils soit le le moins fort
possible en matière culturelle parce
qu'ils sont surtout là pour faire du
développement économique et souvent la
culture ils n'y connaissent rien ils
n'ont surtout pas envie d'y connaître
quoi que ce soit et en plus ils n'ont
pas de légitimité finalement
démocratique pour cela non'ont pas de
mandat du peuple je pense sincèrement
que c'est au au maires dans les villes
de rassembler les acteurs culturel et de
décloisonner ce pays souffre
profondément des cloisonnements des
chapelles quel que soit d'ailleurs le
domaine et il y a il y a tout un travail
à faire là-dessus il y a aussi tout un
travail à faire sur les les équipements
dont on peut disposer il y a pas
forcément besoin d'un théâtre pour aller
faire des musiques actuelles quand on
parle avec les syndicats des musiques
actuells ils vous expliquent qu'ils
aimeraient bien que des des bâtiments
publics leur Soi parfois prêté ou qu'
puissent aussi bénéficier même
d'anciennes usines d'endroits où ne
penserait pas faire de la culture mais
la culture a toute sa place la culture
c'est pas simplement dans un théâtre
avec une jauge de 500 personnes la
culture ça se pratique partout
d'ailleurs c'est un des sens de de la
fête de la musique il faut décloisonner
et le décloisonnement ça passe par
l'implication des des acteurs locaux et
des représentants des collectivités
territoriales juste pour ajouter un mot
euh à ce que vous venez de dire sur le
problème de la libilité bon je suis un
tout petit peu jugé parti puisque en
tant que membre de la commission pour le
relance de la croissance que le
président Sarkozy avait confié à
jacquatali j'étais à l'époque directeur
général d'Orange et j'avais été à
l'origine de la proposition de supprimer
le département malheureusement une des
rares propositions de la Commission qui
n'a pas été mise en œuvre et sans esprit
polémique aucun on se retrouve
aujourd'hui disons-le quand même tout
net avec une
léibilité relative ou une illéibilité
très large pour les acteurs culturels
tant public que privés pour savoir qui
finance quoi et qui est responsable de
quoi donc nous nous avons un travail
actif parce que notre société d'auteur
est présente sur l'ensemble du
territoire on essaie de de se coordonner
l'État à les DRAC et comme vous l'avez
dit vous-même les collectivités locales
sont partagés en leur compéten moi je
plaide pour que pour rebondir dans le
sens de la question qui nous a été posée
les communes jouent un rôle moteur parce
qu'elles sont sur le terrain parce que
c'était l'oget de not table ronde quand
même principalement pour ce qui concerne
l'éducation artistique c'est d'abord à
l'école prim
que les choses doivent démarrer après on
peut faire des choses mais une partie
pour une partie en tout cas c'est trop
tard et que la région soit la
superstructure au sens des découpages
territoriaux qui essae de faire une
coordination entre acteurs public et
privés voilà pour ce qui est de
l'échetons intermédiairees que j'ai du
coup pas besoin de mentionner essayons
de simplifier de rationaliser les choses
merci
merci euh oui
monsieur
James scberg professeur de cancérologie
et de philosophie et littérature donc
j'ai un double
plus je suis américaine et français ma
question est très
simple qui s'occupe au niveau d'un carte
complètement de la France qui permet
chaque personne de comprendre tout ce
que vous êtes en train de dire et
comprendre toutes les activités qui
existent un des plus difficiles choses
pour moi c'est mon premier journé ici
c'est de comprendre et réaliser que vous
avez fait tellement de choses mais la
communication la connaissance de ces
choses c'est la réalité pour tout le
monde de dire mon dieur c'est
extraordinaire et ça commence avec le
premier lycée est-ce qu'on va dans les
lycées trois fois par an avec une avec
des représentants pour expliquer pour
exprimer pour montrer et est-ce qu'il
est possible d'avoir un document qui
exprime toutes les activités par rapport
de toutes les toutes les les les régions
de la France et tous les activités qui
sont faites au niveau de conseil
européen quand vous savez très bien
Madame parce que je fais partie je
représente la France à le Conseil
européen pour la cancérologie mais c'est
un rien à voir avec vre domaine bien
entendu mais la plupart de mes élèves le
plart des professeurs n'ai même pas des
informations qui sont spécifiques dans
les domaines de cardiologie orurologie
c'est-à-dire tous les autres domaines en
cancérologie on a essayit de communiquer
mais c'est mal communiqué donc ma
question finale c'est comment un peu
valoriser les républicaines et cette
partie remarquable pour que tout le
monde devienne
reconnaissante participante et une
véritable valeur individuelle et regroup
et comprendre tous les efforts qui sont
fait apprécier dans de façon positive
constructive dans un période où il faut
changer l'esprit français pour valoriser
cette pays extraordinaire où mes élèv à
Harvard pay 57000 dollars pour
s'inscrire chaque année maises en France
p
365 l'éducation est carrément une valeur
extraordinaire la culture c'est une
valeur extraordinaire dans cette pays et
il faut que tout le monde le comprend
alci je vais euh il y a il y a deux il y
a il y a plusieurs questions dans votre
question euh pour la la plus simple sur
comment faire connaître ce que disent
les républicains là il faut espérer que
la presse impartiel de ce pays rediffuse
nos propositions
notamment en matière culturelle et c'est
vrai que les républicains qui partlent
de culture on va avoir droit encore à ah
ils font quelque chose sur l'identité
nationale ets vont évidemment occulter
toutes nos propositions alors je suis
probablement mauvaise langue et je suis
sûr que dans Libération on verra un
article très différent de celui d'hier
bien sûr après sur la question du
rayonnement culturel de la France
faudrait déjà commencer par défendre nos
équipements culturels ce qui s'est passé
avec l'Institut de France en Autriche
c'est un pur scandale on a laissé
c'est c'est le le c'est quand même le
chancelier autrichien président
autrichien qui ont défendu l'Institut de
France que la France a vendu au Qatar
enfin c'est hallucinant donc voilà où on
en est quand même il y a aussi la la
présence des Français à l'étranger
est-ce que par exemple l'expérience de
la ville la Médicis on ne pourrait pas
la décliner dans d'autres pays d'Europe
ça ça fait partie aussi de nos nos
orientations parce que finalement c'est
un ça marche excellemment bien mais ça
nexiste qu'en Italie et puis par rapport
au
aux endroits où on peut lire tout ce qui
se fait en matière culturelle il y a
tous les portails régionaux euh avec
dans les onglets vous avez les
organismes associés qui existent en
matière culturelle par exemple dans la
région Île-de-France on a Arcadie on a
l'orchestre nationale d'île-france qui
est une saison très riche on a pas mal
d'organismes du spectacle vivant qui
sont liés aux régions et puis il y a le
site du ministère de la Culture qui est
assez remarquablement fait après c'est
vrai que le problème de la diffusion
d'information est lié aux différentes
strates territoriales au fait que la
compétence soit éclatée
oui pour moi votre question je l'ai
trouvé très intéressante parce que par
exemple lors des élections municipales
en 2014 avec David HERV Boutin qui est
ici on avait réfléchi dans notre
programme à à ce problème de de l'accès
à l'information et de l'incitation du
coup à la culture et on avait on s'était
dit mais au fond chaque entreprise
culturelle chaque conservatoire théâtre
musée a son propre fonctionnement de
communication mais il manque peut-être
un fonctionnement plus transversal
et on avait réfléchi même à la création
d'une application numérique qui
permettrait avec les outils numériques
de géolocalisation ou de de d'entrer
voilà de de créer un outil qui permette
de se dire tiens par exemple je suis à
tel endroit voilà l'application va me
dire qu'il y a tel offre tel expo tel
truc de donc c'est vrai qu'on réfléchit
à ce que il y ait peut-être une une une
façon plus intelligente d'avoir l'accès
à l'offre culturelle en effet qui est
immense mais cette à faaire vous avez
raison quicr la fr excusez-moi monsieur
parce que là il nous reste plus que 2
minutes parce que il y a une autre table
ronde qui démarre donc rapidement deux
questions et
monsieur bonjour je me présente monsieur
arant ma question est assez simple la
culture doit être sauvée ça c'est
incontestable mais ne peut ne peut-on
pas faire un effort sur l'accès à la
culture par exemple je vais acheter un
DVD comment puis-je au vu du prix d'un
DVD acheter ce DVD donc c'est ma
question est peut-être anodine mais elle
est importante je pense deuxième exemple
je me permets pour l'accès au château de
Versailles au musées nationaux et autres
il faudrait je pense non l'éducation
l'éducation des jeunes enfants et cetera
il ne faudrait pas tuer dans l'œuf l'é
voocation les les envies d'apprendre la
musique et cetera je pense que la
vocation les vocations sont importantes
et doivent être aussi encouragées et
préservé merci oui alors je propose à
Pascal Rogard pour la la première partie
de la question et à Philippe dallarin
pour la deuxième partie de répondre
rapidement non vous avez raison il y a
un point qui finalement le plus
important de de l'échec global des
politiques culturel c'est l'échec de la
démocratisation de la culture puisque au
final ce sont quand même les populations
les plus favorisées qui bénéficient le
plus de la culture quand même
globalement c'est ce qui ressort des des
études qui ont été faites je crois que
ce qui se passe actuellement avec le
numérique va grandement faciliter
l'accès à la culture parce que le
numérique a une caractéristique qui pose
d'ailleurs problème pour les créateurs
c'est qui baisse le coût et le prix des
œuvres et de l'accès à la culture le
téléchargement la vidéo à la demande
c'est beaucoup moins cher que que les
DVD que les objets physiques maintenant
il y a des systèmes d'abonnement à la
musique où on peut avoir de la musique
de façon illimitée qui sont peu coûteux
donc et puis il y a des politiques qui
ont été mises en place par les
établissements les musées et tout qui
quand même favorisent l'accès à la
culture mais le numérique en lui-même
est un outil un formidable d'accès à
toutes les œuvres mais ce que je
regrette c'est que l'offre légale n'est
pas encore assez développée bon il y a
beaucoup de d'œuvres qui sont pas
disponibles mais avec des prix quand
même qui deviennent extrêmement
compétitif et dans certains cas sont
même inquiétants pour ce qu'on appelle
les industries
culturelles sur l'éducation artistique
effectivement c'est la question de la
démocratisation la démocratisation ça
passe d'abord par l'école parce que
c'est là qu'on touche tous les enfants
donc tout ce qui a été expliqué tout à
l'heure les classes orchestres les
classes Corales les projets de classes
horair aménagé il faut évidemment le
développer mais j'ajouterai une chose
c'est que aujourd'hui le morcellement de
la société telle qu'il ne suffit pas de
mettre un enfant au contact d'une œuvre
d'art ou au contact d'un artiste ça ne
suffit plus il faut un médiateur il faut
quelqu'un qui va avoir le métier la
pédagogie pour faire passer le message
ça c'est très important il existe par
exemple en France on le dit pas assez
mais il y a un corps de de
professionnels qui n'existe nulle part
ailleurs on les appelle des dumistes ils
sont titulaires du diplôme universitaire
de musiciens intervenants ils ont ce
savoir faire ils ont une double
formation ministère de l'Éducation
nationale ministère de la Culture et je
pense que c'est un sujet sur lequel il
faut réfléchir et certainement qu'il
faut le
développer juste oui sur le spectacle
vivant il existe quand même beaucoup de
dispositifs d'accès facilité au
spectacle mais euh ces dispositifs il
touchent un petit nombre de
représentations et on revient au
préalable de départ c'estàd que plus on
diffusera les œuvres plus on ouvrira ces
dispositifs plus on permettra à des
publics euh plus fragilisé d'y accéder
avec le soutien aussi euh de
facilitateurs pour les préparer à la
représentation merci il nous reste à
remercier nos intervenants pour ce débat
riche on aurait bien aimé euh que ça
dure plus longtemps mais on est
contraint tout de même par le temps de
cette matinée merci merci à vous tous on
peut quand même retenir que la culture
c'est dès le plus jeune âge et que les
budgets culturels doivent être
sacralisés je ça devant les futurs
grands argentiers
merci